quoi qu est-ce qui a annon meilleur hier
à six il ya quelque chose vous venez de
faire en regardant ma sculpture
ah mais non mais je voulais dire c'est
joli merci daniel buren enchanté
oui je vous connais un peu basse et sa
hanche ap non ça me dit rien messi mais
j'ai fait des pouces est aussi dénichant
mais attention je les fais beaucoup plus
gros cola par exemple mon plus gros
nichons que j'ai fait trois mètres de
diamètre et là je suis sur un projet
colossal un anus en bronze d'une
circonférence de 8 m d'accord et là le
pousser quoi le rapport avec le cinéma
by toi c'est quoi l'europe ainsi mois
pour rappeler la pellicule des films
j'ai mis des petits carrés blancs dans
les lignes noires et toi tu sais où tu
peux le mettre ton pouce parce qu'à pas
récompensé le proctologue je vois pas ou
quitter monsieur rennes c'est à vous ah
oui j'arrive
et un déjà il ya une petite mise en
scène j'aime bien ça talât oui le tracé
une très très bonne idée ça ralph du
suspense en plus un gros monsieur avec
une barbe qui nous ramène une surprise
ça fait penser au père noël c'est très
agréable
un mois je trépigne d'impatience de voir
ce qu'il se cache sous cette
protubérance oui non mais calme-toi
petula alors présentez-nous votre or ou
là qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde
en tout cas l'épaisseur et la longueur
me plaisent oui mais qu'elles me toi p
tu là bas c'est quand même un peu plus
excitant que la longue colonne toutes
fines qu'on a vu juste avant moi
j'aimais bien les petits carrés blancs
dans les lignes noires n'ont eu enfin il
se branler un peu avec ces lignes le
train c'est moi la rigueur j'aimais bien
côté cylindrique mais là je ne sais pas
il ya quelque chose de plus brute de
plus massif que plus viril
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup et le toit et
ses jeunes dit merci
ça représente quoi au juste ça
représente le cinéma mais oui c'est ça
mais on a l'impression que toute
l'histoire du cinéma étaient compressés
dans ce gros engin turgescent qui ne
demande qu'à exploser
calme-toi non mais oui mais c'est ça en
fait ça représente le cinéma mais comme
près ces bâtonnets attendait là c'est
encore mieux bon après y'a plus qu'à le
peindre en jaune n est bon ah c'est
génial c'est bon là prend 1 quoi mais
non mais de toute façon il nous reste
quelques uns à avoir
à oui c'est vrai merci on vous
rappellera bon bah on vous rappellera
pas me dire que c'est bon la prend
monsieur giacometti c'est à vous tout va
ça n'a aucune chance
un jour j'en mettrais partout dans paris
c'est quand même beau les lignes main
daniel tout blanc avec tallinn